c'est dans ce petit bureau qu'est
dafroza et alain gautier range
soigneusement leurs dossiers chacun
rassemble des témoignages qui composent
des plaintes contre ce que le couple
accuse d'avoir orchestré le génocide au
rwanda en 1994
ils sont chasseurs de génocidaires hutus
c'est arrivé presque tout naturellement
c'est à dire que dès la fin du génocide
dans la mesure où la famille dafroza
avait été quand même cruellement frappé
comme beaucoup d'autres lors de notre
premier séjour au rwanda on a commencé à
rassembler des témoignages dans un
dossier dafroza a échappé de peu au
génocide en 1994 elle était au chevet de
sa mère à kigali
déjà les violences des milices
extrémistes hutu interahamwe avait
commencé terrorisée et quitte son pays
natal en urgence la merde dafroza sa
cousine et des dizaines de membres de sa
famille sont avalés par la vague
meurtrière
sa vie s'arrête mais souvenir
aujourd'hui la date robert ses 94 et je
pense que je ne dois pas être la seule
je pense qu'on est nombreux à avoir fait
une espèce on a chanté o na
c'est comme un black out
c'est beaucoup pour penser cette
blessure que cette chimiste et son mari
professeur se sont mis à traquer les
responsables du génocide qui se sont
refait une vie souvent anonymes
en france elle le fait pour sa famille
mais aussi pour toutes les victimes
mortes dans une cruauté abjecte mourir
d'un accident à la haute parce que la
route elle était très glissante ou
mourir de cinq coups de machette mourir
dépecer au fond de ces latrines
ça n'a absolument rien à voir avec une
mort naturelle avec more more more
naturel non au rwanda les documents
n'existe pas ou à peine
c'est donc sur des témoignages
recueillis sur place que dafroza et
alain appuient leur plainte au maquereau
ya le récit glaçant des victimes mais
aussi celui des complices emprisonné au
rwanda
quand je sors de prison j'ai
l'impression d'être souillé jusque ce
cas mes vêtements jusque jusqu'au mans
l'âme
parfois j'arrive je me lave
j'ai l'impression que je n'arrive pas à
enlever tout c'est sûr que je reçois et
c'est très difficile de voir aussi un
être humain comme vous qui vous parle
qui vous raconte tout ça tu as l'air
normal et qui a pu commettre tous à leur
travail de l'association des gauthier
depuis 2001 est à l'origine de la quasi
totalité de la trentaine de plaintes
déposées en france contre des
ressortissants rwandais
nous avons déposé une trentaine de
plaintes mais si nous avions le temps
les moyens la santé pour et bien
probablement qu'on pourrait on prépare
et beaucoup d'autres mais bon vous voyez
que trente plaintes ont été déposées est
pour l'instant en 27 ans seulement trois
personnes jugées et condamnées donc
encore du pain sur la planche
en mars dernier un rapport publié après
deux ans de travail dans les archives de
l'elysée a conclu à des responsabilités
lourdes est accablante de paris dans ces
massacres
le rapport du clair dénonce des
responsabilité accablante de la part de
françois mitterrand de ses proches
c'est une bonne chose mais nous on
regrette quand même que ça n'aille pas
vers la dénonciation d'une complicité du
gouvernement français de l'époque avec
les génocidaires
après plus de 20 ans à vivre avec les
morts le couple pense parfois s'arrêter
l'idée qui est chaque fois vite chassée
oublier impossible pardonner aussi mais
le dialogue peut être dit dafroza si le
tortionnaire reconnaît sa victime à la
réconciliation c'est un mot que je capte
pas toujours un c'est très difficile moi
je privilégie la justice si on veut se
reconstruire ensemble entre la victime
et son bourreau pour quelle justice
passe
[Musique]